right a congress of representing Ohio's
13th district and he's got all the
answers for you
Anika's eats a 20/20 candidate for the
Democratic presidential nomination Tim
Ryan Tim Ryan just you I understand yes
I saw no you're one of 22 it's like
speed dating at this board yes yeah so
okay so you're running for president
yeah you're on HBO here you got a big
audience yes right you got my audience
yes what more open-minded than most
audiences yes why you
why you another 21 you said it not me
I've got not only a plan but I
understand what the American people are
going through I hear all this happy talk
about the economy the stock markets up
the unemployment rates down the reality
of it is most people are still
struggling to make ends meet I've been
living that for the last 45 years
outside of Youngstown Ohio thank you
we got one everywhere I'm telling and
and I've been studying trying to figure
out how do we get this economy working
for working-class people I mean we've
got no different I'm telling me what
everyone is no but I'm here's where I'm
different okay I know what direction we
need to go in I know where the economy
is going where it's well right now what
do you know they don't right now nowhere
but we've got to get in I'll tell you
I'll tell you quickly the economy is not
horrible 44.4% is the unemployment rate
in Ohio it's kind of hard to run against
the economy in Ohio isn't it no because
you know the average wage has only gone
up 20 bucks right a week big this is not
work wages did finally rise after after
after how many years okay but not many
Dec right but Trump is president for two
years we can't ignore that fact
yeah but finally wages went up he's the
guy in the office do you feel better
I'll go back I'll go back two weeks ago
and talk about a General Motors plan
just laid off 1,700 people I'll talk
about a trucking company just laid off
600 people you know they found out a
text message
I'm telling you Bill this is the
underlying issue in the come trying to
get to that one Democrat I said this
place we go this year I said I feel
owned you know they always say they
owned the libs yeah I mean when you talk
about this [ __ ] where they can't do
anything
I feel owned and I don't like that
feeling so I'm looking for the Democrat
who make me not feel owned I'm looking
for the Democrat who's gonna stand up to
the Twitter mob are you willing to do
that to stand up to to the people who
are woke well here's here's
look at that even an ally audience wants
to stand up to the woke winning this
election is going to be about who's got
the plans for the future or the economy
I'm listen to what I got to say I know
be there to the question listen yes of
course I am I look I can stand up to it
I've taken on Republicans I've taken on
Democrats I'm not afraid I represent my
people right and right now my people
have not had a fair deal it's not going
back a few years it's going back 40
years wages are still there they're
creeping up 20 bucks a week and the
president's running around saying
there's a boom in the economy they still
got debt they still got credit card debt
they still got student loan debt look we
need to move into the future economy
there's about one to two million
electric vehicles today being made in
the next 10 years there's gonna be 30
million electric vehicles made I want
those made in the United States I want
the batteries made the United States I
want the charging stations made in the
United States will you tell the people
there's cold cold people in your state
coal right yeah will you tell them coal
is last century we are moving on we'll
retrain you we'll help you but we're not
sending you back down into the hole well
did you tell them that
but that's not what they vote for they
love Trump who says I'm sending your
back into the hole you guys who cares
you guys can't sell we'll get you out of
the hole no look one we didn't we didn't
even go into states like that we didn't
go into rural Hillary did and then we
turn around and then we say why don't
these people vote for us because we
don't go there let's go into these
communities tell them that we're they're
gonna be building electric vehicles tell
them they're gonna be building solar
panels tell them they're gonna be wind
turbines and when you look at the
president it keeps talking about China
China dominates 40 percent of the
electric vehicle market we have dominate
60 percent of the solar panel market
we've got no plan so as president I'm
gonna have a plan for how we dominate
these so that's a good example we were
talking about it before Paris came out
today Trump is putting more tariffs on
China it's gonna make our goods cost
more he doesn't seem to understand that
but I read in the paper furniture air
conditioners handbags fish soap fruit
pet food everything we're gonna teach
these Johnnie's a lesson we have had it
up to here with you making the [ __ ] we
buy okay so I keep reading we're paying
more it's hurting his and mostly his
voters Democrats can't make that an
issue
you can't sell people on he's costing
you money they are hurting I mean we're
not running the array in just now but
they're not leaving him well they don't
have a chance yet we've got to go and
talk to those people we've got to have a
rural agenda we've got in places like
Iowa and Ohio and Michigan and some of
these other places we've got to go there
and tell them we care about them that
they're they're not deplorable that we
like them that we love them and we're
gonna rebuild their community and here
are jobs that are gonna come and here's
the other thing we got to stop talking
about they say Democrats what's your
economic plan say 15 bucks an hour
nobody wants to make 15 bucks an hour
that's a social justice issue right
people where I come from we're making
3040 bucks an hour now they're making 15
an hour
that's not where they want to be we've
got to have a bigger agenda a more
aspirational every Democrat gets asked
the question about
we just got some votes okay so every
every Democrat gets asked the question
about socialism and I would I would love
to hear a Democrat just say well we are
already a quasi socialist country was a
socialist country and that's good
but it's probably enough is that your
position yes you're not on the socially
I your cap that we need to fix the
capitalistic okay period end of story
and I'll tell you if you want to if you
want a reverse climate change you better
align the environmental incentives with
the financial incentives if we don't use
the power of our free market if you
don't use the power of our free market
if we don't use the event the powerful
venture capital community that we have
in the United States to to try to
decarbonize our country we're not going
to get there in time this needs to be an
urgent matter
you